an underwater garden
bursting with color
scientists call this coral bed the field
of roses stretching nearly three
kilometers off the coast of tahiti it's
one of the largest of its kind
so now we will do our first dive along
the reef of roses to see how deep they
go we're going to an unexplored world to
explore the unexplored it's quite
motivating and exhilarating
coral reefs like this are hard to find
anything below 30 meters is called the
twilight zone an area low in oxygen and
difficult to reach but rare living walls
like this
keep drawing scientists down
other famous coral like the great
barrier reef off australia have been
bleached by harmful human waste and
rising sea temperatures the marine life
around them is suffering and
disappearing too
but scientists are surprised by the
condition of this particular garden
seemingly unaffected by pollution it's
pristine
this is looking awfully good
so
i think it has managed to dodge the
bullet but
you know
the question is how long is it going to
be before we get an event
that's
that deep in that location and uh and it
suffers the same phage
until then this underwater labyrinth is
blooming with hope leah harding al
jazeera
okay let's talk to julian barbier he's
head of marine policy and regional
coordination for unesco he joins us from
paris julian welcome to the newshour
what is it that's unique about this
particular area that it's managed to
avoid being impacted by all the
negatives that we are making and putting
into our oceans
well i mean first of all i think it's a
great positive story about the state of
our core reefs you know we've we've
heard in the last
year only that
you know since the 1950s we've lost
about 50 percent of our core reef cover
globally so finding a a reef structure
which is so extensive uh at a depth
which we don't usually find or expect to
find uh this kind of structure is quite
amazing the fact that indeed as your
your reporters said that you know the
reef is in a very good in a healthy
condition
it's been able to dodge the impact of
climate change of pollution and and
overfishing which are the main
core of killers but it also opens up the
fact that you know maybe we're not
looking in the right places to find some
of those reefs and you know we are very
little of our ocean which is actually
mapped in high resolution we only have
about 20 percent of our ocean seafloor
globally which has been mapped and when
you think that this information is
really the basis for ocean management
for protecting biodiversity
that tells us that we need to invest
much more in the science
in finding out where those ecosystems
might be where we're not certainly
looking for them but also we need to
make sure that they are well conserved
in the future that's an astonishing
statistic that we've only mapped 20 of
our oceans so that means we've mapped
more of the surface of the moon than we
have the waterways on our own planet but
very briefly because we are running out
of time
what's the lesson that we can take away
from this and what can we learn from it
well i think we can certainly learn that
we need to study those riffs and and
even though coral reefs are probably one
of the most studied ecosystem
there's a lot of things we still don't
know and i think coming up with a
understanding what type of biodiversity
leaves under those coral reefs will be
very important uh we we anticipate that
there are still many many species that
can be found and when you look
at the uh so for those those systems
whether in terms of providing potential
new cure new medicines uh i think we
need to invest much more in in finding
out where they are
and protecting them through uh for
measures and this is what unesco is
trying to do with world marine heritage
sites and biosphere reserves so that
countries have a tool to uh to protect
and sustain those ecosystems in the long
term and for future generations okay
thank you so much for joining us here on
the newshour julian barbier they're
talking to us from paris